[Music]
jackson kansas city hey jack how are you
i'm doing very well how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
uh i had a question about uh purchasing
a vehicle in today's climate for my wife
uh
the
it would amount to purchasing two
vehicles at the same time basically
okay so riddle me what are you talking
about
well i've been i've been driving a
vehicle for about 20 years
as my everyday vehicle
i inherited it from my father brand new
basically he
he bought it brand new and then got
diagnosed with a terminal illness and
ended up passing away soon after
and so that was about 19 and a half
years ago
i've been driving the car
it's a subaru race car
um
long story short i've been taking it
only the dealers and my local dealer
kind of wrecked the last time they
serviced it trying to install a clutch
and destroyed the transmission and
did a bunch of damage
and basically ruined the car for me
so they're gonna pay you for the car
uh they we made a deal we came to a deal
oh that avoided anyone going to court
and so they're going to sell me a new
car
and give me a bunch of money off on it
basically to me the equivalent of the
value of the other car
yeah plus a little bit over i think
because
well yeah i'm sure there's margin in
that thing so
there's margin in them that are there
so you're getting a brand new subaru
yes okay so that that deal is done oh
base model basically that deal is done
and what are you spending there
what are you spending on that car uh
it's going to cost about 25 000. okay
what's your household income
uh our household income is about
200 okay and you're wanting to spend one
on your wife's 20 20.
so here's the thing the dealer felt bad
and he told me i told him my wife needed
some work on her vehicle as well then
and he said
he would give her the same deal he's
given me if i wanted to buy her one
so
i wasn't thinking about getting her one
before he said that
he's going to give you the price of your
old car off of your wife's and your car
or just a good price
gonna give me all the money he's given
me off my deal and he said he'll do the
same thing for her he'll give her the
same money off as if he'd wrecked her
car
and just because he feels bad he says
how much did they give you for your old
car
for the old car
uh it's leaking out of the head how much
money did they give you for your old car
oh for my old car yeah uh they basically
gave me about
four or four thousand for my car okay
and then they knocked off how much more
the car then they knocked off how much
more they knocked off another three
okay so they're gonna knock seven
thousand off of another subaru if you
buy two in a row
basically yeah and and your wife is
driving what now
she's driving a subaru that's uh
what's it worth
uh it would be worth about seven or
eight except that it's got to have the
leaky head gap itself cost three four
all right so it's gonna it's gonna
you're gonna be able to sell it for five
right
yeah if i fix it no if you don't fix it
if you fix it it'll sell for seven maybe
or eight
yeah yeah i guess yeah
it's just it's drivable it's just got a
leaky head gasket and it's an old
freaking subaru now what is your network
what is your net worth
net worth i just did a calculation i
think our if i go by just net worth
we're at about
230ish thousand i guess
okay
between equity you have the cash to pay
for all these cars
no
well only if i take money out of a roth
account or something so no we're not
buying these cars we're not buying cars
without i have the cash to pay for one
car okay
okay
um
but my mother's been telling me
you know maybe i should be buying some
reliable cars yeah maybe you should but
maybe you shouldn't be going and taking
your retirement money out to do that you
probably i'm going to pass on this i'm
going to pass on the second one because
i don't recommend people buy new cars
that go down in value like a rock
except for in the last 12 months
unless they have a net worth of in
excess of a million dollars because that
way you can accept the blow on that so i
would save up some money and i would buy
your wife a better car that is used and
i would forego this sweet dealer's offer
which is really not that great an offer
anyway it's an okay offer
but it wasn't like he gave you like half
off the stinking thing or something so
he basically gave up his margins is what
he did and he's got you back on the hook
for more work in the
uh and everything else in the in the
shop but no i i'll pass on the second
one i would save up and buy her a better
car and i would pay cash for it and i
would not cash out my retirement but we
don't borrow money to buy cars we don't
buy cars where the total of all your
vehicles is more than half your annual
income and i don't buy brand new cars
unless they're a million dollars unless
you have a million dollar net worth or
greater and here's why because they go
down in value and you need to be
concentrated on things that go up in
value yeah and in this situation i'd go
and fix the super for the wife and then
save up save up you're going to get a
decent amount i think dave you're right
going to get 7 or 8 for it if it's fixed
up and then you put that into the
savings and all of a sudden we've
upgraded pretty substantially without
any kind of debt it is doable and people
get the itch and i don't i don't fix six
thousand dollar cars at the dealership
either no
uh i fix six thousand dollar cars
independent mechanics where the cost is
about half of what it is to fix a car at
a dealership
and so um if you have a brand new
vehicle and you know whatever and you
spend a ton of money on it you make a
lot of money and you want to take it in
for the dealer to service it that's one
thing but you don't take a six thousand
dollar car into a head gasket job into
the dealership you're gonna pay double
what you'd pay with an independent good
mechanic shopping around so do some
shopping around i i'm not doing it no no
so a subaru with a hundred thousand
miles is just getting warmed up yeah
well that's okay i mean i don't mind him
moving up and no but you can by the way
i forgot to tell you the federal law too
wife gets the good car
that's the federal law so that means she
gets the new one you get the one with
the bus the head gasket y'all about to
trade cars out so this is how that works
that's a marriage thing they're just
helping you